(somber music)
- [Voiceover] My mom is amazing person.
- [Voiceover] Jannet
Castanon and Rosario Vargas
are a mother and daughter
separated by a border,
one living in San Diego
and the other in Mexico.
- I came from Mexico, 2006,
because I want to get
opportunities for my kids.
- [Voiceover] I don't have the permission
to cross the border, the line.
From the last year and a half,
I see my mom through the fence.
- [Voiceover] At the site
of a bi-national park
in San Diego,
the U.S. Border Patrol
allows families to meet.
On the weekends, loved ones enter the park
and walk directly up to
the border, a steel fence.
This gives families on both
sides a rare opportunity
to see and speak to each other.
- You know you're gonna see your mom,
you're gonna see your family.
But the fence only have tiny holes,
and my mom sometimes put
the finger in the tiny hole.
Just a little touch, it just touches.
Or sometimes I give a kiss.
- [Voiceover] On April 30th,
for the third time ever,
authorities agree to open the door,
allowing such families a
brief moment to embrace.
Each of them will only have three minutes.
- Right now, I feel so
happy, because I'm waiting.
I'm waiting so much this moment.
- For the third time ever,
we have the opportunity
to have this door open.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
(inspirational music)
- (sighs) I feel
incredible.
She was so happy.
She was so sweet with me.
She tell me, "I love you."
Mommy, I love you so much.
I love you, I love you.